Welcome everyone. My name is Rahul
Singh. I'm a staff AI research engineer
at Fedra.
>> And I'm Vance Kulistik. I'm a senior
engineering manager, also at Fedra.
>> And today we want to talk about the time
when we gave an LM 500,000 sensor names
and it got confused. We call this
problem semantic blindness.
At Fedra we build AI agents for AI
factories.
This includes agents which allow our
customers to talk about their data
centers
and explain to themselves and understand
how the data centers are working and
what problems they are facing on a
day-to-day basis.
User queries can be anything from what
chiller is running hot to analyze the
distribution of temperatures across my
data halls to is
any of my GPUs facing any problems?
Now from this variety of
queries you can see that these include
talking what specific equipments is
chiller six all right to talking about a
groups of equipments GPUs in data hall
one.
The industry has not really figured out
a common naming pattern yet and every
single customer can have their own
things from simple names like racks with
GPUs with data halls which give you an
exact idea of where different things are
to something that is more difficult to
comprehend like
CH3 something something six. We've seen
all kind of names in the industry going
forward.
Now when you're building a demo system
this works because you're working at a
small scale. A a simple LM can
look at all the names of your equipment
and figure out what user is talking
about. But this problem really becomes
intractable as you go to for scale.
For example at 1 gigawatt scale
factories you will see 400,000 plus GPUs
and to support those GPUs you have power
meters, you have chillers, you have
other equipments.
LM context windows are finite and you
will very quickly saturate uh and it
just becomes a problem.
Like we say, a product is something that
works for all scenarios and does not
fail silently. A demo just has to work
for one.
>> In addition to having the LLM figure out
these names, uh
we could also have uh embedded them in a
rack database, a vector embedding
approach. But, the problem is often
times the names are so similar that
semantic search just fails. Uh there's
very little difference between a vector
of Sorry, a string name of 20 characters
long which just differs by, let's say,
one character. Chiller 6 instead of
Chiller 7. Or uh CDO something
uh versus, well, something else. It's
very small. So, you get a lot of uh
problems with getting accurate uh
recall.
Also, LLMs suffer from what we call a
frequency uh penalty. If you keep on
outputting very similar names over and
over again, or very similar tokens, uh
more accurately, over and over again,
there are internal penalties in the LLM
which just shut off their output. So,
if the user says, "Can list all the
names of uh let's say GPUs in i7?" There
are, let's say, 100. Just by listing
through them, the LLM's guardrails would
see uh think that well, it's spiraling,
and it would just shut the system up.
So, we can't really have these two
approaches. RAG would not work.
Just naive LLMs would not work.
As we move into production systems, we
need something that can scale as the
system scales. Now, there are naive
solutions which we shall discuss going
forward.
A naive approach to solve this problem
would be just to well, divide and
conquer. Take your different uh
equipments, branch them in different
shards, and pass them through LLMs. Uh
parallel calls should work, right? Well,
that's what we thought. The problem is
you get horrible recall and
hallucinations.
You will see LLMs invent phantom
equipment that do not exist, and also
silently drop things that do exist. Now,
this creates a problem for
mission-critical systems where the users
need to know exactly what is happening
with their systems. Any problems there
will quickly erode user trust. At the
same time, you will miss on specific
problems which can cascade into bigger,
bigger problems going forward.
Anyhow, something that we realized here
is that as the size of these physical
infrastructure grows,
LLMs can not the LLM-based solutions can
not grow with the size of individual
components or instances or nodes.
They We have to find something that
grows sub-linearly with increasing
equipment count.
And this is what we figured out.
So,
we should not grow with instances, we
should grow with tree depth. Now, what
do we mean by tree depth is
we realized that there's a hierarchical
structure in which an AI factory is
arranged. You will have data centers,
then each data centers will have
different data halls, you have
each of them will have different aisles,
and you will have different rows and
then racks and then GPUs. Similarly, a
chiller plant will have rooms where
chillers are arranged, then you will
have pumps.
There will be a separate cooling tower
unit. It's kind of like a tree.
The depth of the tree grows very slowly,
the width grows extremely fast. In other
words, you will have a hierarchy that
only adds new equipments very rarely,
but it adds a lot of them when it does.
You will have a lot of GPUs, but without
GPUs, you won't have a lot of things.
Now,
we realized that this could be used to
solve our problems.
And there are four insights that really
come into the picture for this. One is a
linearizer.
What I mean by the linearizer is
the LLM has to figure out where each of
these things are arranged and how to map
from a vague user query to specific
equipment or groups of equipments.
Here
a
summarized representation of our
system's graph can be really, really
useful. For example,
uh
if you're uh
a 1 gigawatt scale factory can have over
a million nodes and each node represents
a unique equipment.
But, because you want to go from the
root to the leaf, all you have to do is
describe all the paths and that's a very
small finite list. For example, here you
can see that to get to a GPU, you can
just you just need four different layers
to get to it. To get to a chiller,
similarly four layers to get to
switches, similarly four layers.
With this,
64 GPU layer
sorry 64 GPU
system and a 460,000 GPU system produce
roughly the same size of summaries.
This consolidated context gives your LLM
all it needs to know to figure out how
the distribute how a plant is arranged
and how different equipment are
distributed in that plant.
The second insight that we had was LLMs
are good for planning but not good for
searching.
This is what we realized when we saw
very poor recall with our sharded
solutions. So,
instead of making the LLM sift through
all the different fuzzy names that we
can get from our users, we asked the LLM
to give us exactly how to look for them.
So, for example, here the query says,
"Give me all the GPUs that are running
hot in data hall 11."
The LLM does not need to go through all
these names of all our GPUs to figure
out which one of those are in data hall
11 and then figure out how they are
running hot.
All it needs to do is structured outputs
which tells us that well, we need to
collect GPUs. The scope under which we
need to collect is a subtree which is
just data hall 11
and the filter that we need to apply to
finally figure out what exactly we need
is GPUs that are running hot. Now, this
can be different things depending on the
context and you can implement different
filters. All we need to know is how do
we create the set that we want to know
get to.
The third thing that we realized is that
once you have a structured output to
figure out what exactly you need, uh
building the back end for it is
relatively simple and straightforward.
Now, all we need to do is create
different uh subsets of uh our equipment
or pre-index trees as we like to call
them based on their location and based
on how they interact with other uh
equipment around to get an idea of what
you need to look at. So, for example,
from the previous uh slide we saw that
we wanted to look at GPUs in data hall
11. We could just get all the GPUs in
data hall 11 in one pre-index subtree or
other data halls, for example, or other
racks, for example. And then to get to
the final result, all we need to do is
uh run a query to find all GPUs that are
running hot and take their intersection.
Set operations ensure that we have
perfect recall and accuracy irrespective
of uh how we want to filter uh the
queries and what uh you know, fuzziness
the user may have in their query.
Next slide, please.
Yes. And finally, uh
what if you have something that is very,
very vague? In which case, uh
you have to get the LLMs to get to
searching, but instead of searching
directly over names, we figured out that
getting the LLMs to
uh give us patterns to look for. This
could be uh patterns in the data but in
the names can be much more useful to
figure out uh what the user is talking
about instead of just passing the entire
name list uh to the LLM.
The LLM never has to see uh
very large number of tokens. All it
needs to do is uh see some patterns in
the naming convention, figure out what
exactly the user is talking about,
create a pattern, and then we can
execute it uh on the back end on our
side. This makes sure that the LLMs has
a constant or relatively constant uh
cost of operation. Whereas if we had to
read through everything, we would have
been scaling linearly with increasing
equipment count, which itself grows
exponentially as the size of the system
increases.
Finally,
to process a user query end-to-end, we
go from the user's query, which could be
anything from one equipment or a group
of equipment, to a planner LLM, which
figures out user's intent and gives us a
search pattern. Based on that search
plan, we have a deterministic resolver,
which indexes, does set operations,
figures out exactly what we need to do,
and creates the final set that maps to
the user's query, and this is what we
call the result set. All of this is a
two or three-step process instead of
a multi-step agentic loop, which can
keep on running over and over again. And
this keeps our total cost also
relatively flat and constant.
>> Cool. Yeah,
if Rahul's job is to design the
architecture, my job is production
readiness.
So, we need to make sure that whatever
we designed, the elegant solutions we
came up, actually hold up under real
load, real customer data, and all the
messy edge cases you only ever see
production.
So, before any of this went near a
customer, we put it through some
extensive tests and evals.
We measured the new system head-to-head
against the old ones with same LLM
model, same data,
and we did three runs per case just to
make sure.
Our goal was simple,
prove that Rahul's solutions are ready
for production.
And they definitely are.
If you look at some stats here, the old
approach degraded pretty fast at scale.
So, we got 80% correctness at 64 GPUs,
and that dropped to about 30% when the
GPU grew to 400 460,000.
On the other hand, the our new approach
has maintained correctness with 100%
accuracy across all of those um
tests that we give it.
And this is not just synthetic test. Uh
this is also a real data. So, we we had
66 cases on six real production systems
and they product
they produce zero failures as well.
And not just correctness, it's also
dramatically lighter.
So, when we talk about 1 GW scale uh
data center, the old approach burned 116
million tokens for just a single
validation pass
while still having a lot of errors.
If you look at the new one,
it's a 390,000 tokens, which comes to
around 300 less tokens fewer tokens.
But the part that matters the most, the
cost is flat.
As as Rahul was talking about before,
the the system grows
in size, but we the cost of the query
was 9,000 tokens a query where the
system was 64 GPUs or 460,000.
So, instead of getting the cost grow
exponentially
w- when the customers grow their
systems, it stays the same.
That's the impact. Now, there's
something about uh what we learned and
the part I want you to take back to your
own work.
It starts with a lens from Karpathy.
Most of you have probably seen his
presentation or his framing talk about
this before.
He talks about different kinds of
software.
Software 1.0 is a deterministic code you
write. It's predictable, exact,
but a lot less flexible.
On the other hand, we have software 3.0,
which is basically a behavior you prompt
out of an LLM.
In our case, that might be show me the
GPUs in data hall 11 that are running
hot.
The This is very flexible, smart, but
it's a bit fuzzy.
Now, his observation was that in legacy
software, the 3.0 is steadily eating
1.0.
More of what used to be deterministic
code becomes a prompt.
Just hold that picture because the
lesson for new built AI native systems
runs a little bit the other way.
But the real skill is knowing which work
is the LM not best for.
And
you always want to keep the thing the L
LM should be used for the things that it
does well. It's great at parsing
ambiguous requests,
judging where to look for data and what
to look for,
handling phrasing we've never seen from
a new user that has a different query,
and at the end also synthesizing and
writing the final human-readable answer.
But But everything you you can data
model, you should move into code.
This is the key one especially for large
systems. If your data has structure,
call it a hierarchy, graph, or a schema,
a language model scanning it token by
token is definitely the wrong tool.
Both retrieval, exact set logic,
counting, dedup across near identical
names, which happens a lot in the data
center land,
anything that must be 100% reproducible,
it should be a deterministic code.
The simple heuristic that usually works,
if you can write down the structure or
the rules, it's a 1.0 job.
And pure LM is weakest exactly when the
system is large and well structured,
which is precisely where we operate and
our customers.
So, in a sense, we ran Carpathia's trend
backwards. We started almost pure 3.0.
We threw everything in the context
window because that is the fastest way
to find out what's even worth building.
And as we said, it worked pretty well on
a simple demo to start.
Then, as it had to really scale, we
moved the parts that can be treated as
known engineering problems into 1.0.
And we still kept the hard judgment in
the LM.
So, that's the inversion. Legacy
software drifts from 1.0 towards 3.0 and
new AI native software starts at 3.0 and
matures towards 1.0
for the use cases that earn it, of
course.
We are not here to replace model
judgment. We want to feed it with the
1.1.0 tools, as we call it.
So every 1.0 function you add is more
reliable ground for the LLM to stand on.
So to finish up,
let the LLM keep the hard decisions.
Everything it shouldn't be guessing on,
add add it in as code and hand that
structure back to the model to work
with.
So develop with software 3.0,
productionize by adding in software 3.0
1.0.
Thanks for watching everyone. Uh any
follow-up questions at all, you can
reach us by email
Rahul Russell Google at fidra.ai,
Lanza at least to get fidra.ai,
or you can drop them in the video
comments below.
>> Thank you for watching.
>> Thanks.